ich fragte sie jetzt mal für einen
freund wie man so schön sagt wie
transportiere ich denn meine wünsche an
meine freundin also wenn man was neues
ausprobieren möchte andere orte andere
stellung und 3er beispielsweise wie
mache ich das überrascht da meine
freundin einfach und schmeißt sie rein
in die situation um setzt man sich
wirklich hin an den küchentisch und sagt
du schatz ich muss dir da mal was sagen
also was du gerade gesagt das finde ich
ganz toll also immer dann wenn man sich
zb ein paar abend aussucht einmal die
woche kann man solche themen doch gut
ansprechen und da gilt es ja auch darin
oder da geht es ja auch darum nicht mit
der tür ins haus zu fallen sondern
einfach auch da wieder in kleinen dosen
die wahrheit zu sprechen also zum
beispiel wenn ich von von dem 3er
träumen dass man das wenn ich so eine
fantasie teile das ja nicht gleich
heißen muss dass das morgen passieren
muss sondern das kann ich irgendwann mal
sein aber einfach sich trauen darüber zu
sprechen und dann erfährt man auch dass
man eine ganz andere nähe zu seinem
partner bekommt also immer dann wenn ich
was für mir ganz persönlich erzähle
entsteht nähe und dann traut sich
nämlich auch der andere darüber zu
sprechen und auf einmal hat man eine
sehr lebendige beziehung und sex ist ja
so viel mehr als nur sagen wir mal eine
anzahl von nächten wir haben das jetzt
auch ein bisschen runtergebrochen auf
diese zahl vier fünfmal im monat sex ist
das okay ist das zu wenig ist das zu
viel aus ihrer sicht oder ist diese zahl
eigentlich ganz egal
ach ist doch wurscht am ende gibt es
doch wirklich darum dass der sex sind du
zu hause mit einem partner hast super
ist und dass er dir spaß macht und dass
du dich darauf freut und vorfreude ist
lust wenn der sex langweilig ist oder
immer nach dem gleichen system abläuft
dann hab ich da einfach keinen bock
drauf und dann habe ich weniger 6 mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur weil
bild schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren